bien le bonjour chers camarades
aujourd'hui on va jouer un jeu fait par
des procès il s'appelle turpitudes
renvoyer leur jeu en exclusivité jeu
très content merci à eux je vous
présente matches des matches dit pas
comment ça se dit c'est un simulateur de
tender mais en français on va jouer un
jeu en français c'est historique c'est
génial le but est de draguer nana par
messagerie jusqu'à la pécho comme le
vrai tender de nombreuses techniques
sont possibles
lové bof fragile fans de jul pour
débloquer les différentes fins très bien
eh ben c'est parti mc afee choisira at
c'est génial patricia 30 insistante en
cabinet dentaire
ouais diana esthéticienne camille
mannequin grande taille luiz 22
apprentis dresseuse d'ours
et ben voilà piteux j'ai toujours voulu
trouver des apprentis dresseuse d'ours
un mec mais faut que je change and selon
cette chaîne c'est bien clément qui
veulent à faire les vidéos me dit non la
change pas mais il faut que je la change
il faut juger un jour je vais mourir je
me briser la nuque tu seras au chômage
paiement well with alors comment séduire
louise elle écrit elle écrit en première
c'est bon signe
salut et lowell bébé ravie de faire
votre connaissance gentes dames tu suces
non non non celui-ci en plus de madère
vidéo naïade j'ai eu des bons lots la
bonne réponse notre en plus et ben moi
je vous dis vraiment lots en plus voilà
c'est un faux incroyable ça va envoie
une digue pic c'est bien ça attention
est-ce que casse toi sale boulot ce
louise vient de vous bloquer voilà on
voit que j'ai beaucoup expérimenté le
vrai tinner ça se voit on va dire bien
et toi voilà comme ça moi on est serein
très bien parfait tu m'envoies ravi oh
merde ça les emmerde ça moi d'enchaîner
l' allemagne l'allemagne
tu vas voir une photo des puciers attend
ça se trouve elle kiffe ça soit elle
aime les pieds aussi alors le diable
vous bloquez vous êtes en df tout
certaines pendant deux heures avant
d'aller vous promener dans une
chaussette en pleurant fait un point sur
votre vie c'est urgent je savais que ça
passerait pas ça je vais attendre qu
elle reparle
c'est ça c'est long les mecs virils qui
font ça qui arrive à ne pas parler qui
laisse le temps
alors qu'est ce que tu fais sur match
dit ah ça a marché je suis
principalement là pour baiser des
grosses boîtes et toi on est franc n'est
pas franc je suis là pour faire des
rencontres le reste on verra après
wahlbeck qu elle mais qu'il est là genre
ouais juste votre des gens par les
espèces de pythons tu veux pécho tu vas
trompette au zizi pardon moi je dirais
on est franc je suis principalement là
pour baisser
moi je suis là pour me taper un maximum
de mecs ça tombe bien ça ne pose pas de
problème
non non pas du tout mdr non surtout pas
non mais on peut apprendre à se
connaître avant c'est bien ça c'est bien
ça cool bon je t'explique j'ai mis au
point une technique et scientifique pour
savoir si on est compatible un
questionnaire hyper pointu ça ne dérange
pas tu es folle tu es juste vol
alors comment ce nouveau cinéma tu
préfères quoi oh [ __ ] je fais le coup
et on se retrouve après pour ainsi si
c'est la cata décidément on est vraiment
compatible et musicalement c'est
hyperimportant [ __ ] les gars savent
erc et sur sa der question we can do it
gets coups de touches hausse du métal
c'est pour les nazis bob doll j'écoutais
tout sauf durable pour les raquettes
j'écoute de tout ce qui m'importe c'est
les émotions que ça véhicule
c'est beau ça là je sens que il va se
passer quelque chose avec louise voilà
maintenant je sais ce que j'ai fait
comme mais tu dois passer un entretien
d'embauché cela c'est quoi la j'ai eu
mon bac et je suis youtuber hockey était
mal placé pour critiquer parce que tu es
dresseuse d'ours maaf a assez bien le
dire je crois pas que le cursus face la
personne
ouais mais non ça c'est vraiment la
phrase du mec à qui a eu ses hauts
diplômes j'ai levé le bac je suis allé
un peu à la fac il c'est bien ça ah je
regarde je vais manger d'ailleurs c'est
quoi ton plat préféré
[ __ ] et me rend ouf un bon plat fait
par ma petite femme quand je revis taf
du boulot c'était un match où ça dépend
j'adore cuisiner donc je vais te dire un
mes petits plats fait avec amour tu es
l'homme parfait ma parole
et si je te dis que je suis vegan
allergiques au gluten et intolérantes au
lactose tu chantes tu chantes jeunes
acceptent elles que tu es moi même je
suis allergique aux salles hippie
bouffeuse de graines
c'est vrai que c'était par des mecs
qu'on veut voir infliger quelques tout
drôle
j'accepte la différence et j'essaye de
te comprendre car aucun de nous donna
raison
nous avons juste chacun un point de vue
différent at à des animaux de compagnie
chez plus si on en a parlé [ __ ] mais
meuf mais là elle me scan j'en ai marre
et le scan plus que quand à l'aéroport
je passe aux rayons x quoi tu as mal sa
balle est chiante
je suis plutôt team chien merde à la
première grosse erreur j'espère que
c'est pas trop un problème pas de
problème ils apprendront à se connaître
comme nous tu as des obus dans la vie
non mais là par contre j'en peux plus
non mais je n'en peux plus
oh [ __ ] les amis elle a posé 18
questions d'affilée je n'en peux plus là
il dit parfait on continue un peu des
questions must est folle et franchement
j'ai pu j'ai envie de te bloqués j'ai
rarement vu le glauque et pas de souci
ça me plaît ce petit jeu donc ça c'est
la réponse qu'il faut mettre à bas ce
mytho tu veux pas du tout aux belles
toiles à avant faut être franc non mais
voilà pourquoi pas si tu réponds juste à
deux questions hockey
schopenhauer se place en héritier de qui
bon on va dire je sais pas mais que je
sais pas on va dire que c'est l'héritier
de quand tu allais seul que je
connaissais les fans de nouna se font
appeler les nababs une question des
philosophes poursuite elle parle des
fantous doivent [ __ ] les fans vous
allez vas-y
allez allez au special hockey vient
maintenant vous décrochez un rdv avec
louise le courant passe bien et elle
vous propose de rentrer chez elle
arrivée là bas vous vous sentez un peu
chelou il voulu demander où sont les
toilettes et un an ressortant vous
constatez que la pièce portières et
tapissés de plastiques elle vous attend
mieux au milieu de la pièce une hache à
la main il faudra plus de deux mois pour
vous mangez en entier mais c'est pas
grave elle a un grand congélo american
psycho vous finissez en kebabs mais non
ils bouffent de l'humain quoi [ __ ]
elle couche avec des ours elle bouffe
des humains ça ça n'a pas de sens très
bien
eh bien c'était la première fin très
bien alors on a une serveuse une
déscolarisés une étudiante en led est un
cabinet dentaire un chef de projet
junior toinon tu m'as manger donc le
plus toilé à 19 ans étudiante en lettres
d'un mot site ce match c'est parti ça
lui ravie de faire votre connaissance
gentes dames à ma lecture en être à un
moment il faudra à tien un poète tout
père est un voleur il a pris les étoiles
du ciel et les a mises dans tes yeux
oui j'adore tout ce qui est poésie
victor-hugo mylène farmer et c'est bon
alors qu'est ce que tu fais ce match on
va dire pareil je suis passé par le bras
pour baiser des gosses réponse et la rue
croyable moi je suis pour taper un
maximum de mecs ça tombe bien elle
répond paris que l'autre qu'elle veut se
taper un maximum de vagabond dit oh que
non avec ladite pic
ok je t'attends vous décrochez un rdv
avec les à quoi le courant passe bien
range 7h leur arrivée là bas vous vous
sentez un peu chelou et vous lui
demander où sont les toilettes et en
ressortant vous constatez que la pièce
entière et tapissés de plastiques des
africains pour le mec votre jeu est ce
que léa et louise sur doivent être la
même fille
en fait je pense que la fin est lié à
mes réponses et vu que j'ai mis la même
réponse que tu à leur bal à la fin était
la même voie là sauf que tu as l'air je
lui réponds d'avis en question avec
l'âge j'ai juste envoyé de photo de ma
[ __ ] morale de l'histoire on voyait
toujours une photo de votre bits
dans le doute adèle serveuse aller à del
bon alors tu fais quoi sur match des
jeux cherche le grand amour la passion
je veux des enfants est vite ça ça va
lui clair ça ça va vraiment la mettre en
confiance elle a vraiment vouloir sortir
avec moi at-elle moi aussi je cherche la
plus belle des passions c'est quoi pour
toi ce qu'il ya de plus beau au monde
l'amour avec un grand a
la vie avec un grand v ton cul avec un
gros string l'amour avec un grand a
ces héros restent à jouer le poète
pendant cette game c'est bien ça oui
décrit moi pour toi la dette parfaite
bougies pétales de roses jazz et bon vin
pour te faire rêver champs de blé
bouteille de champagne et ciel étoilé
pour te faire voyager députés doutent
jul pour te faire toi requête pardon
bougies et pétales de roses nucléaire on
se la joue l'honneur aux éleveurs les
gars de mieux en mieux j'ai envie de
rencontrer maintenant j'accours je vole
un signe de vous êtes un arc en ciel
dans la grisaille automnale de mes nuits
ouais on a vraiment répondu ça ouais
ouais je sais je suis choquée moi aussi
au parfait mon beau damoiseaux vous
décrochez rdv avec adèle voulu acheter
un bouquet de fleurs et quand elles
arrivent vous l'utilisez un poème que
vous avez écrit en chemin elle fait
demi-tour et s'enfuit pour entrer chez
vous tête basse et posté un odieux
article misogyne sur votre blog en
disant que toutes ces put ne vous mérite
par connais un peu de recul vous ne
saurez jamais avec cette attitude mon
p'tit vieux canard coincoin ah bah voilà
pourquoi on fait jamais les poètes parce
qu'après tu es petit tu as deux canards
voilà mesdames
allez vous plaindre à nos copains clara
déscolarisés c'est la dernière on va
tout donner wesh bébé on y va cash et
ben tu perds pas de temps toi ok je lui
ai dit que j'aimais gueuler fume un peu
ghetto genre le parrain psychose
apocalypse now j'adore même genre en
juin photo des séries tu suis quoi toi
alors niveau ces lyonnais plutôt d'eric
louis la brocante et joséphine ange
gardien classe est enfui en courant
et merde des comédies modern family
community french tout ça bien sûr et
musicalement
j'écoute du jul et toi j'adore c'est
quoi ton morceau preuve ces bourses à
oicha alors bien sûr ouej alors et tu
cabrés comment on y jeu je crois que je
vais te voir maintenant sans le cross
volé car même si la roue et vous allez
viens à moi vite vous décrochez rdv avec
lara elle arbore un t-shirt loose vous
tombait à genoux et l'a demandée en
mariage directement vous enfuyez vers
marseille en scooter cabré bien
évidemment y auto-tune vous cabré même
si la roue et vous allez et ben c'est
une excellente fin pour mettre fin à
cette vidéo et la junte tient pas de
cdisation match du bas merci à un tueur
futur de l'avant voyez c'était hyper
rigolos les gab ça me fait plaisir des
petits jeux indés français comme ça
n'hésitez pas et même
vous a plu à télécharger le jeu si vous
voulez voir les autres fin j'en ai fait
que 4 sur 13 saper le match dit je
m'excuse aussi sur android et ios voilà
ou alors mais bien surfer studio
aujourd'hui c'est la famille je vous dis
à très de la prochaine ouverture
regarder portez vous bien sûr tout le
monde je pars or y frère
[Musique]
ça